Film Courage: What makes 99 of screenplays
unreadable?
Jim Agnew, Screenwriter: I think it might
be the story.
It depends.
Probably every one is there's a different
problem with them but they all have problems
because I've seen a lot of these but what
you need to think about too is the reader
they don't think about who's reading it and
the person reading it if they're professional
has a stack of scripts you know sky-high in
their office so you need to understand like
if you don't grab the person the first two
three pages you know and you hear this all
the time but sometimes you even need to like
have something happen that might not happen
like that in the film like you know is there
a scene you know on page 23 that's super exciting
okay why not put that two or three pages of
our section of it at the very beginning and
then create a flashback or do something so
that the it's exciting and really reads like
a professional script at the very beginning
and that's the other thing it has to read
like a professional script which means the
dialogue has to be well executed it has to
move it has to have beats you don't want to
get bogged down in minutia you don't want
to you know do exposition you have to show
don't tell but the thing is it's not hard
to get copies of screenplays nowadays because
the internet has everything so there's a movie
like your movie see how they did it you know
but you have to really grab people right away
it has to be you know professional all the
way through but if it's not professional first
five pages they're just gonna you know be
like what is this you know and you're asking
someone you know to take an hour two hours
out of their life to read your script so it
better be perfect you know and you better
really do your work or else you're wasting
people's time is that when a script consultant
might be helpful because let's suppose everyone
you know is going to just tell you it's great
and they've never met written a movie before
yeah a script consultant could be helpful
there's some things you just intuitively either
are going to figure out or you're not but
you know you can you can get a script consultant
to take you maybe to the next level or show
you things you're doing wrong like I said
my view on that is is they're good as long
as you don't spend a lot of money because
I've had people come to me asking me to fix
a script or saying hey can you do this I spent
fifty thousand dollars on this script I paid
somebody to go to write it and they're like
somebody's never written a script so you have
to be very careful that you don't you know
lose your ass financially so but you know
it could help you know there's so many classes
out there there's so many things but I just
always go back to watch movies they're there
they show you how to do it it's already been
done for you you know and just figure out
how your story fits into that formula and
just kind of like find those beats but that's
why I think why 99 of scripts are just they're
not ready and they're not at a professional
level you know if you get there it takes a
lot of work to get it there and do you think
that people gave up too soon on some of those
unreadable scripts or that there's just no
way to sort of it's just lipstick on a pig
you can't really fix it yeah probably probably
both but I think a lot of it's just not doing
the work you know you just it's not some magic
thing you know I think people have this you
know you know they envision you know smoking
cigarettes writing in the middle of the night
you know like it's glamorous it's not glamorous
it's like if you really want to get good at
the people who make a living in it are people
who just you know stick to it you know grind
it out rewrite it rewrite it rewrite the other
day I found there was a project I found like
let's clean out my computer I found like 40
drafts of the script you know it's like that's
a lot of drafts so you know and that's what
you have to do is really grind it and work
on it and make sure you know you get the professional
level and like I said you can find all these
scripts online you know if it's anything that's
similar you can find it if you you know you
want to do a movie about a guy in a food truck
you know John Favreau did (Chef movie) watch
that you know you know by the way he's one
of the best that like beats in a film watch
his films they all have the same rhythm and
the same beats it's there yeah I love Chef
that was great yeah so you saved each draft
of that screenplay you did it for you you
had 40 drafts and you saved each one this
is you know just date them now because there's
so many on so many things so yeah what's the
purpose of saving each draft of a revision
just to kind of keep track you know I mean
probably not really anything you know that
has to do with screenwriting just that's my
process it's just easier to kind of like you
know I also back everything up on email and
things like that and another backup but but
you know you never know when you need it or
go back to something that like you took out
so I sometimes get a little crazy to start
cutting stuff out too I can I can like just
chop chop chop and then sometimes I chop too
much so I'll be like oh wait that was good
what was that one scene where the guy couldn't
aim the gun because he was shaking I cut that
out so I'll go back to older version and find
it just cut and paste it back in what really
irritates you about reading other screenplays
what irritates me is just when people haven't
done got it to where it should be at a level
of reading you know where they send you something
and they go oh don't read that wait I got
this one or I changed that or you or do you
read it you talk to them they're like oh I
changed that it's like well that means you
know there was that famous Josh Olson article
[Deadline - 2009] which you can find online
about reading people's scripts which you know
it's like if it's not ready to be read don't
send it to me because it's like like josh
had mentioned it's like asking somebody come
over to your house and paint for two hours
you know you're taking up two hours of somebody's
time you know so don't give it to them to
read until it's like perfect and there you
know and if you want my notes and I give you
some notes don't be defensive about it either
that's the most irritating thing it's like
don't say I want I want your opinion and then
you give somebody opinion or you say you need
to fix this okay great thanks and they're
they have an attitude about it it's like you
know why'd you have me read it just tell you
it's great is it okay to question why you
gave a certain note is that yeah oh yeah definitely
definitely yeah oh yeah of course and and
you know what do I know as much as I know
I don't know anything so it's like you know
sometimes my notes might not even be valid
it's just this is what I think you know but
sometimes people don't even want to hear that
they just want they just want you to tell
them it's great did you ever catch that in
yourself and really work on that it sounds
like you're okay with with negative feedback
it gets easier you know so I mean it all kind
of depends on who it comes from too it's like
you know I mean if if somebody reads a script
of mine that's like never written a script
and they were like I don't like this and that
I mean probably my knee jerk reaction like
what do you know but if it's a producer somebody
who I respect and who's done a lot of work
then I listen to him but it does get easier
to take the negative feedback and like like
I said before it's about interpreting notes
too sometimes people can't explain why they
don't like something and you have to figure
that out would you say that 99 of what Hollywood
makes is garbage no there's some garbage but
no I think I think most films I mean most
films get started with very good intentions
and look I've made a few movies that I'm not
happy with either but the process is not a
singular process you have to deal with producers
actors you know money guys distributors like
even the Nic Cage movie that I wrote it wasn't
called rage the distributor called it Rage
you know it's like really Rage okay nobody's
gonna make fun of Rage in the Cage you know
but I had no control over that so it you lose
so much control in the process that you know
it takes a very very strong director like
somebody like Quentin Tarantino who can say
no to everybody and filter out the bad that
comes along you know that's you know you're
making you're doing art by committee so that's
why sometimes things they have great intentions
maybe it was a great script maybe the actor
was amazing but things got messed up along
the way because there's so many people's hands
on the editor you know the composer the director
there's the screenwriter the producer who
shows up on set and wants to put a motorcycle
chase in the middle of the movie that makes
no sense and then you find out later it's
because he can get a free BMW motorcycle if
we put him in the movie things like that happen
so you know that's why sometimes movies don't
work out but I think most screenwriters and
directors almost all of them have the intention
to make a great movies just things get in
the way or lack of money or resources so if
someone's at a certain level then there's
so much more creative control because they
can basically say no to people you need that
like one per that's why score says you can
make but you need a strong director or writer
director who can like no one's going to question
that because then it at least keeps everything
focused there's very few of those people you
know but like I think Paul Thomas Anderson
I don't think any producers are going to show
up or money guys and tell them what to do
you know so it's or Quentin Tarantino or Christopher
Nolan that's why they can make really great
films because the white noise that's going
on around them they can just stop you know
or just ignore it or people just scared even
you know mess with them because people want
to get their ideas into film too you'll have
you know money guys who you've never even
met who gave some money on a film show up
and like give an idea and then other ones
are great and actually have good ideas so
you know there's just so many people that
are involved in a film that it's hard sometimes
to keep it focused so I think that's the problem
with things that sometimes because there's
a lot of moves on Netflix you know look like
they had good intentions and like I said I've
i've worked on a few that like start off over
here and ended up over there you know it happens.
Question For The Viewers: What percentage
of the screenplays you read would you say
are unreadable?